a moment MEP s have been waiting for
Alexis tsipras in the house to present
his case as Europe and its currency
spiral down towards a political and
economic you nightmares own he delivered
promises of reform between words of
plain Dnieper valina po o de Pedra da
mihi meted rapido del Este append
erroneous inna Parramatta Co air gas
theory little ITA's topi Romano's preppy
all Nepali motive embeds a Protoss a
pocket of editors mas in The Prodigy
boobarella money actual pistol metal if
mrs. material possible in TV a katana
mitten were on for some MEP is he failed
to persuade seal even had tsipras the
provocation via Linden compromise Salim
- iton on villain dinner fault
ceasefire Europa Ponte de Lima robot for
others this is a defining moment as an
electoral accident who made its people
poorer in his country all want to be
remembered mr. tsipras as a real
revolutionary reformer so that you're a
real leader and not a false prophet do
it Nellie seduction or obey en la hora
tight related or degree C so no start a
dawn a war mini que no se Buddha meted
apart a rail or o kazakh la loire apart
Renza política de ferran a toady
responsibility' EDI consult Evita Persil
Varela Greta a person bar la Rafa
mr. tsipras had plenty of support in
Parliament from those opposed to
austerity from different groups who knew
papa Felisha people capitalists let-7 a
looper Madiba this shoppi aloo the Greek
people have said that they cannot go
longer with this austerity that we need
to have a sustainable and a fair deal
for Greece even if we sign off an
agreement with Greece by tonight the
longer lasting effects on the mindset of
the European people of this experience
are going to be nothing but negative
that's for the future for now mr.
tsipras his government will add details
to his reform package on Saturday the
Euro group meets to consider whether
it's enough for Greece's 18 eurozone
partners Sunday all 28 EU heads meet in
emergency summit I have avoided talking
about deadlines but I have to say loud
and clear that the final deadline and
this week